Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and last night
the trailer for the new Gotham TV Show dropped
so I wanted
to do a breakdown.
Basically as you can tell it’s like Arrow
told from Quentin’s perspective.
Like a dark crime drama noir-ish cop show.
With superheroes floating around in the ether.
I know a lot of you have been asking me if
I think the show is sustainable, if they can
make it for four or five seasons.
So I’ll address that too.
If you ever read Batman Year One the comic
or saw the cartoon movie they made.
Think of this like Detective Gordon Year One.
Although technically the series picks up right
when Bruce Wayne’s parents are being killed.
I would expect that to go down in the first
episode.
This is a Fox show, but they paid a dump truck
of money to get the rights to use all the
good comic book characters, except for the
Joker.
No Joker.
Right now the roster is Ben McKenzie as Gordon,
I never watched him on Southland, but I’m
going to give him a chance.
Jada Pinkett Smith as Fish Mooney.
She’s going to be a gangster, not from the
comics.
But in the universe the show is creating she’s
going to be the boss of the Penguin.
Who’s being played by Robin Lord-Taylor.
So this is like a very very young Oswald Cobblepot.
So I’m curious to see if he gets his Penguin
nickname on the show or if he’ll already
have it in the first episode.
If Arrow has been any indicator of how shows
bestow comic book identities on characters,
we can bet that all the people on the show
will just start out with their regular names
and slowly evolve into their comic book personas
over time.
Which I’m totally fine with.
Going down the rest of the roster there’s
also the Selina Kyle Catwoman played by Camren
Bicondova.
She’s not related to Michelle Pfiefer, I
swear.
But the resemblance is uncanny.
So I’m excited to see what she what kind
of energy she channels into the character.
Alfred Pennyworth is being played by Sean
Pertwee.
You might have seen him as Lestrade on Elementary.
He’s a lot beefier than Jeremy Irons who’s
playing Alfred in Zack Snyder’s Man of Steel
sequel.
I think this version of Alfred will be the
ex-british military one that the animated
series explored.
So expect him to be a very punchy smashy version
of Alfred.
That’s a big change from the Michael Caine
Dark Knight Alfred too, so let me know how
you feel about Alfred turning into a brawler
as opposed to a very polite society old world
person.
Personally I don’t mind.
I think it will be an interesting twist.
Especially since Bruce Wayne is a little boy
on the show.
He’s being played by David Mazouz.
He and Selina Kyle are going to be about the
same age on the show.
But here’s where it gets interesting.
They’ve also cast roles for Poison Ivy,
Clare Foley.
She’s going to be Ivy Pepper when the show
picks up.
The Riddler played by Corey Michael Smith.
Also starting as Edward Nygma and the Bette
Kane Batgirl.
She’s going to be played by Sara Paxton.
Because she’s so much older than the rest
of the other supers I’m betting we’ll
see her transformation into Bat Girl during
season 1.
And she’ll fill the Batman vigilante void.
There’s a bunch more secondary characters
like Bullock played by Donal Logue, Erin Richards
is playing Barbara Kean, Gordon’s wife.
And Crispus Allen is being played by Andrew
Stewart Jones.
That’s pretty much it for the comic book
characters, but this is only the first season.
Remember how Arrow brought on Black Canary
and The Flash in Season 2.
The show itself was ordered to series, which
means we’ll see Episode 1 in the fall.
They’ll probably air the pilot at Comic
Con though.
So if you make it you can see it early.
I’m going to be doing weekly videos for
it just like Arrow and Agents of SHIELD.
What I’m hoping to see is a lot of Bette
Kane Gordon scenes, Jada Pinkett Smith and
Oswalt Cobblepot and Alfred Bruce scenes.
But really I think what we’re all waiting
for is all the young comic book characters
to interact with each other pre-persona.
Like young Bruce Wayne running into Selina
Kyle and Ivy or seeing how the young villains
interact.
Just like most characters I don’t think
any of them will be super evil right away.
Usually they have to experience some major
trauma.
So expect Jada Pinkett Smith to do terrible
things to Oswalt Cobblepot and I’m sure
Selina Kyle is going to get terrorized.
But let me know what you’re looking forward
to most?
Really I am super pumped to see all the characters
meet each other before they get their masks.
It adds a really cool dynamic to the world
of Gotham when you know what their endgame
is.
As for them making it to four or five seasons.
I think they can do it, but one of the issues
they have is having to pay Warner Brothers
extra money on top of the production for all
the comic book characters.
Arrow on the other hand is made by the CW,
owned by Warner Brothers, so they don’t
have a lot of the added costs Gotham will
have.
But Fox has a much larger audience than the
CW, so the idea is that they make it up on
all the extra advertising money they get.
I think we’ll know after the first couple
of episodes whether or not season 2 will be
a thing.
I think it’s totally possible though.
And like I said, I’ll be doing weekly videos
for this when it starts airing, but I’ll
try to do more bonus videos for it as we learn
new things.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And leave me suggestions for what you want
those bonus videos to be about.
Right now click here to catch up on Arrow,
there’s only two episodes left in the season
and it’s been really freaking good this
year.
And click here to catch up on Agents of SHIELD.
Also, only two episodes left.
Hail Hydra.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!